[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat il ya un peu plus de
cinq mois naissait sur les réseaux
sociaux un mouvement citoyen spontané le
mouvement des gilets jaunes principale
revendication le pouvoir d'achat un
combat comment avec certains partis
politiques et syndicats
du coup ces derniers ont-ils toujours
leur légitimité c'est le thème de ce
débat et pour en parler autour de cette
table quatre invités safia mathari
bonsoir bonsoir et gilet jaune dans les
yvelines à vos côté randy nemo zone soir
nous est coordinateur de la france
insoumise pour le bassin de versailles
et de saint quentin en yvelines
en face de vous sonia porot bonsoir
bonsoir en êtes secrétaire départemental
de la cgt
dans le département des yvelines à vos
côtés je crois backs de chitine ce soir
vous êtes responsable des jeunes
républicains dans les yvelines
merci en tout cas tous les quatre
d'avoir répondu raison en ce soir safia
mathari vous êtes mobilisés depuis le 17
novembre
j'imagine que vous le sera encore ce
samedi pour l'instant quel est le bilan
que vous faites de ce mouvement des
gelées jaune
le bilan du mouvement il est en fait il
est le même que 17 novembre
c'est à dire qu'on
on est sortis dans la rue parce qu'on se
sentait pas écouté et aujourd'hui cinq
mois plus tard mme se sont toujours pas
écouté après la fin du grand débat voilà
on a l'impression que le gouvernement
continue sa route tranquillement mène sa
politique et n'écoute pas à la
population qui est en colère parce que
pour tenir cinq mois il faut quand même
avoir des choses à revendiquer qui sont
importantes pour nous alors paraît
justement du gouvernement qui a précisé
que la république en marche avait été
convié à ce débat en raison des annonces
des manuels mâcon prévue demain jeudi 25
avril je cite le parti est en trêve
médiatique
randy nemos commencé positionner la
france 1 sont mises dans sa par rapport
à ce mouvement dès gilet jaune revient
ou depuis le début on a soutenu les
gilet jaune
il ya beaucoup de militants la france
est soumise qui qui ont enfilé les
jeunes et qui sont allés dans la rue
soutenir le mouvement parce que nous on
revendique on a faim on a les mêmes
revendications c'est à dire plus de
justice fiscale plus de justice sociale
et nous depuis le début on pense que oui
un problème s'il ya une caste kyi qui
défend des intérêts privés au détriment
de l'intérêt général et du peuple
pourtant début ça fait amateur il me
semble que les gels et je ne voulais pas
être apparentée avec un parti politique
qu'est ce que c'est toujours le cas où
est-ce que ça a évolué au fil au fil des
mois
c'est toujours le cas en tout cas ça
dépend des personnes évidemment par
exemple ma part je suis toujours à
syndicales à partisane c'est à dire que
je ne souhaite pas
me rapprocher d'un quelconque parti
politique ni d'un syndicat après au sein
des gilet jaune il ya plusieurs
mouvances entre guillemets donc il ya
certes un gilet jaune qui sont syndiqués
et qui
naturellement revendiquent leur
appartenance à leur syndicat pour les
partis politiques c'est plus compliqué
ils sont beaucoup plus discrets
vis-à-vis de leur parti maintenant c'est
voilà c'est quelque chose qu'on
revendiquant même depuis très longtemps
on veut pas se faire récupérer ni par un
syndicat ni par un parti politique un
geoffroy backs de keating même question
pour la france en sont mises au niveau
des des républicains au comment votre
parti s'est positionné par rapport à ce
mouvement depuis le 17 novembre
alors les jeunes depuis le début c'est
un mouvement qu'on a soutenu comme la
majorité des français de toute façon si
vous regardiez les sondages au moment où
le mouvement s'est lancé une majorité
des français le soutenir à 70%
parce que de toute façon ce que les
gilets jaunes portés c'était un
ras-le-bol fiscale
c'était ont une revendication du pouvoir
d'achat d'avoir plus de pouvoir d'achat
et même j'irai même du pouvoir de vivre
s'étaient portés par une majorité des
français
les classes moyennes et les classes
populaires et puis avec le temps ce
mouvement il s'est un petit peu
transformés puisqu'il a été phagocyté
par des mouvements d'extrême gauche
il ya eu des violences etc qui ont lieu
durant ces derniers mois et je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui comme une grande partie
des français on commence on sait on
s'est détachée aussi de ce que
représente le mouvement des gilet jaune
puisque on ne peut pas cautionner cette
violence et il y à un cadre aujourd'hui
un cadre démocratique
il ya eu le grand débat il ya même les
instances les prochaines élections il
faut que cela cesse les violences
cessent et que les gilet jaune se
rassemblent s'organisent pour peut-être
porter un projet à des prochaines
élections
alors on rappelle un plus de 300000
personnes lors des deux premiers actes
sonia porot niveau de la cgt est-ce que
vous soupçonniez là
la montée en puissance j'ai envie de
dire de ce mouvement des jeunes qui est
une très grande colère et des attentes
importantes d'une grande partie de la
population sur les questions de service
public de salaires de conditions de
travail
on le sait très bien puisqu'on est au
quotidien dans les entreprises avec avec
les retraités avec les les privés
d'emploi donc là dessus c'est pas c'est
pas un étonnement et d'ailleurs on a
fait de fortes mobilisations sur c'est
sur ces questions là le le 14 mai encore
les retraités vont faire une caravane
dans dans le département le 9 mai il ya
une mobilisation pour les services
publics et la défense du du statut de la
fonction publique
donc cette colère là ne nous surprend
pas c'est plutôt la forme la forme
qu'elle a prises
et les forces aussi qui se sont
impliqués impliqué dedans
le mouvement n'est pas non plus
totalement totalement spontanée il a été
beaucoup aussi diffusée par par les
réseaux sociaux où on sait que ce sont
les groupes d'extrême droite qui sont
allés plus les plus influents et on a
voix sur un certain nombre de points
voilà des des vrais des vraies
divergences ou des vrai questionnement
sur sur ce mouvement dans sa globalité
il peut y avoir des variations locales
évidemment alors tout le monde autour de
ces tables défendez mesure évidemment
pour donner plus de pouvoir d'achat aux
français justement le 19 avril dernier
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques a estimé que le pouvoir
d'achat des français va augmenter en
moyenne de 850 euros dès cette année la
moitié de cette hausse proviendrait des
mesures prises pour répondre à la crise
des gilet jaune je pense notamment à
l'augmentation de la prime d'activité la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires ou encore la prime de
fin d'année la prime macron il s'agirait
de la plus forte hausse de pouvoir
d'achat depuis 2007 qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce chiffre
je crois pas que ce qu'estime avant de
répondre à cette question je voulais
quand même dire quelque chose qui est
très important c'est que je suis quand
même assez choqué de vos deux discours
l'extrême gauche d'un côté et l'extrême
droite de l'autel et gilet jaune y sont
infiltrés par l'extrême droite par
l'extrême gauche
les jets les jeunes sont violents donc
je me sens insulté par ses propos je
pense pas être quelqu'un de violent j'ai
participé à la déclaration de très
nombreuses manifestations
j'ai d'ailleurs c'est un discours en
fait qu'ils aient tenu assez
régulièrement puisque j'étais en plateau
avec la sénatrice les républicains des
hauts-de-seine qui avait ce même
discours sur la violence et c'est donc
quelques dizaines ou centaines de
personnes sur des milliers de gens des
dizaines de milliers de gens des
centaines de milliers de gens ont peut
pas en faire une généralité
il ya des personnes violentes dans tous
les mouvements dans toutes les
manifestations en france depuis la nuit
des temps il ya des gens violents dans
la société je veux dire c'est un morceau
de la société voilà aujourd'hui les
gilet jaune c'est pas des personnes
c'est pas des séditieux
c'est pas des gens qui sont là pour
tacler la démocratie ou je ne sais quoi
au contraire on est là pour la protéger
la démocratie
on est là pour demander à ce que le
citoyen on retrouve son pouvoir
politique
parce qu'en fait la démocratie c'est
quand même le citoyen la base c'est le
citoyen qui compte c'est ni les
syndicats ni les partis politiques ni
les chefs d'entreprise un film
alimentation politique et puis dans les
manifestations des syndicats
les manifestions sont encadrés vous avez
de la sécurité qui vient des
manifestations et s'est donc prolongé
aujourd'hui ce mouvement des gilets
jaunes qui qui est un mouvement
populaire incliné qui n'a pas
d'organisation réel c'est aussi
permettre à ces gens qui s'infiltrent
dans ces mouvements de pouvoir opérer
leurs environs allongez vous répondrai
simplement déjà venu avec moi on va
organiser une manifestation semblait
vous verrez comment s'organise la
dernière manifestation à laquelle j'ai
participé on avait plus de 200 bénévoles
donc je pense que pour un mouvement pas
organiser c'est quand même pas mal des
gens qui étaient là pour faire la
sécurité etc et ensuite à la préfecture
de police de paris lorsque j'ai été
déclaré les manifestations on leur a
parlé des gens violents on leur a
demandé pourquoi est ce qu'il est laid
c'est agir puisqu'il ya des arrestations
préventives en marge des manifestations
on nous a répondu on ne fait pas une
d'arrestations préventives en france ce
qui est totalement faux
donc c'est peut-être aussi une volonté
du gouvernement de laisser ces violences
s'installer pour ensuite pouvoir en
parler dans les médias puisque les
médias le rappelle se sont pas
appartiennent quand même à des personnes
qui sont assez proches d'une réponse oui
alors moi j'ai pas j'ai pas aborder la
violence et s'il y en a eu et qu'on
condamne clairement et qu'on combat
c'est aussi celle contre les libertés de
manifester contre et contre les
manifestants on était d'ailleurs le 13
avril dans la rue à ceux à ce sujet là
on a intenté des recours contre l' usage
du duel bd et on ya été confronté dès
2016 dans les mobilisations contre la
loi travail à ces restrictions de
manifester à cette gestion des forces de
l'ordre qui est extrêmement
problématique
voilà un syndicat ça se place dans un
cadre qui est différent y compris d'un
d'un parti politique
on organise sur la base de valeurs et
d'intérêt commun
des travailleurs voilà que soient des
jeunes futurs travailleurs des des
retraités et on le fait dans un cadre de
valeurs et de principes qui sont pour
nous fondamente haut c'est-à-dire qu'on
pose un certain nombre de règles qui
nous sont communes qui nous permettent
justement d'être ensemble ce qui empêche
pas d'être ouvert et d'accepter une
diversité une diversité d'opinions mais
on a des camarades qui sont allés sur
des ronds points de gilet jaune qui
n'ont pas caché leur appartenance
syndicale et qui ont été rejetées nous
on n'est pas dans l'imposition voilà à
vouloir représenter tout le monde on est
à défendre quand même une très large
partie de la population puisque quand
même les salariés ex ou futurs sont
extrêmement nombreux dans dans ce pays
est qu'aujourd'hui les organisations
syndicales restent dans une région on va
dire sociales elles les organisations
les plus les plus importantes
numériquement randy moss oui alors nos
partis politiques en un autre rôle
par exemple c'est de proposer des lois à
l'assemblée nationale et c'est ce qu'a
fait la france insoumise suite aux
violences policières pour l'interdiction
du lb des voix là parce que vous
dénoncez les violences des
manifestations très bien nous aussi on
les regrette
mais il faut aussi dénoncer la dérive
autoritaire la violence policière qui
s'accentue bonjour aujourd'hui encore
des journalistes qu'on envoie en garde à
vue pendant 48 heures et on vous entend
pas souvent
pour le coup dénoncé la violence sociale
les mesures d'austérité qui ont été
imposées depuis notamment la crise et
même avant quand votre parti était au
pouvoir il ya quand même dix mille morts
aujourd'hui des conséquences du chômage
chaque année il ya des gens qui meurent
dans la rue qui meurt dans la mer
méditerranée
ça c'est une violence sociale qu'on ne
voit pas et il faut la prendre en compte
il faut la dénoncer et je pense que la
colère aujourd'hui qui ressort des jets
les jeunes elle est aussi dû à ses
injustices et à toute cette violence
sociale qui reste un petit peu sous les
radars
on va juste revenir par rapport à ce
chiffre du du pouvoir d'achat 850 euros
donc c'est ce que nous dit à
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques par rapport aux mesures donc
mises en place comme logo
sur la prime d'activité je me tourne
vers vous alors vous disiez ne pas être
entendus par par le gouvernement il ya
quand même eu des mesures qui ont été
prises pour ce fameux pouvoir d'achat
oui des mesures qui étaient prévues dans
le calendrier de la république en marche
on a un calendrier présidentiel
c'est ce sont des mots c'est simplement
une accélération de mesures prévues
l'augmentation de la prime d'activité
était prévu donc après comment dire ce
qu'on demande c'est pas ça à ce qu'on
demande c'est pas 50 euros par 6 50
euros par là on n'est pas des mendiants
moi j'aimerais bien que les gens qui se
lèvent le matin et qui vont travailler
n'est pas besoin de primes d'activité
pour subvenir à leurs besoins
j'aimerais bien que ces gens là il n'est
pas besoin de toucher les apl c'est pas
normal aujourd'hui de se lever de tra de
travailler 35 heures est de rentrer chez
soi et de d'aller remplir son dossier
caf pour toucher de l'argent
on n'est pas des mendiants ont travaillé
puis les personnes qui malheureusement
ont perdu leur emploi n'ont pas droit au
chômage autre chose comme ça ce sont
aussi des êtres humains ils ont c'est
pas parce qu'ils touchent le rsa qu'on
doit les traiter comme des comme des
moins que rien c'est pas des rebuts de
la société donc aujourd'hui on est dans
une société de l'image et du paraître on
est dans une société où allah il faut il
faut gagner plein d'argent il faut avoir
une belle maison il faut avoir une belle
voiture il faut avoir le dernier
téléphone à la mode etc
et puis si on n'a pas ça on n'est rien
voilà on n'est rien du tout monsieur
macron la dit quand même il s'est permis
de le dire mais je pense que les gens
qui vont nettoyer ses toilettes et qui
lave par terre c'est pas c'est pas rien
c'est c'est des gens qui contribuent la
société aussi et ces gens là c'est pas
normal qu'ils aient besoin de mendier
des aides sociales
ben moi je trouve assez assez assez
paradoxal qu'on en soit venu dans la
société à se dire qu'une partie de ce
qui est en fait une solidarité on ait
l'impression de mendier mais c'est
effectivement 20 ans de discours contre
les chômeurs et les précaires alors
effectivement oui qu'on ait besoin d'un
complément à son salaire pour vivre
correctement ou un peu moins
misérablement
c'est un souci et c'est pour ça que nous
à la cgt on parle pas de pouvoir d'achat
mais on parle de salaire y compris sa
partie socialiser c'est à dire toutes
les cotisations
qui sont de la solidarité et qui sont
aussi une contribution des entreprises
parce que aujourd'hui le gouvernement
effectivement mène une certaine
politique mais qui correspond aussi aux
intérêts du patronat et nous on se place
dans cette conflictuelle qui
conflictuelle it est là et c'est aussi
voilà ceux qui travaillent qui
produisent des richesses qu'ils font
dans des conditions de plus en plus
difficile parce que la productivité
augmente qui a pas assez d'emplois que
les horaires sont de plus en plus
déstructurés et ses passes et ses
revendications là et on veut que les
gens vivent bien dans leur travail
vivent bien de leur travail et on repose
on repose les choses comme ça et
effectivement les mesures qui sont qui
sont prises ne met absolument pas en
cause les responsabilités des
entreprises que ce soit dans les niveaux
de rémunération finale mais transition
démonstration mesure où mesure êtes-vous
les appeler comme vous voulez c'est
finalement grâce au gilet jaune
finalement qu elles ont été prises ces
mesures et non au säntis cas je pense
pas par exemple sur la hausse de la csg
pour les retraités ça fait plus de deux
ans que les retraités sont mobilisés de
façon unitaire est extrêmement
importante
il ya très régulièrement des
mobilisations dans des entreprises et/ou
des augmentations de salaire sont tenues
des embauches ont obtenu ou au combat
des plans des plans de licenciements et
cetera donc tout ce travail là aussi il
est il est pris en compte et et les
revendications elles étaient elles
étaient portés avant après qu'on ait en
tant que syndicat face à un monde du
travail qui a été effectivement
fortement bouleversé ces dernières
décennies
des évolutions qui sont compliqués à
prendre en compte la sous traitance la
précarité va tout le développement des
services à la personne mais on y
travaille on y travaille depuis
longtemps voilà on a par exemple un
syndicat d'assistantes maternelles dans
le département et des salariés aux
particuliers employeurs qui est
extrêmement actif pour des métiers
justement féminin peu reconnu voilà très
mal très mal payés et pourtant essentiel
à la société
en fait on peut augmenter les salaires
des personnes qui travaillent mais en
fait avec la fiscalité que l'on à la
fiscalité et à l'état obèses qui a une
dépense publique qui est démentiel avec
une dépense qui est la plus élevée de
l'union européenne dépense publique
tant qu'on n'a pas baisser la dépense
publique ne pourra pas baisser les
impôts des français et on aura toujours
ce même souci là qui est le le besoin de
pouvoir d'achat
en fait les salaires c'est qu'une partie
du problème mais l'imposition de la
fiscalité est principalement est la
principale cause justement de ce
mouvement populaire qui est né j'ai
lentement des généraux de la justice
celle inverse
en fait c'est ce que l'on dit depuis le
début nous au républicain on était parmi
les premiers à dénoncer cette fiscalité
qui augmentait sans cesse tout ce que
l'on demande c'est la baisse de la
fiscalité mais cette baisse de la
fiscalité les français ne sont pas dupes
elle ne peut pas elle ne peut pas être
financé sans baisser la dépense publique
parce qu'il faudra bien qu'on trouve
l'argent quelque part mais celle inverse
l'argent il existe il ya des millions et
des milliards dans le cicr qui est
parent versées aux entreprises qui n'ont
pas créé d'emploi à ce niveau là et la
dépense publique ce sont aussi nos
services nos services publics ce sont
les routes ce sont les hôpitaux ce sont
les écoles et tout ça aussi améliore
laquelle la qualité de vie donc ces
dépenses là et toute cette
redistribution là c'est ce qui fait
aussi que la france est pourtant la
situation s'est fortement dégradée
malgré tout à un niveau d'inégalité mais
c'est tellement érodé qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui oui ça se vient ça devient
intenable pour beaucoup avant d'y mourir
sur des mois par les gleek
on est des services qui se dégrade on
est le pays qui a la plus forte dépense
publique mais les services publics se
dégradent comment on explique cela ce
qu'il ya énormément de cannes aux
entreprises qui ne vont pas justement
dans les investissements au service
public
on sait rien un petit peu du débat randy
nord-est et un problème en fait le
ras-le-bol fiscale c'est surtout un
sentiment d'injustice fiscale
on a l'impression que c'est seulement
les classes moyennes qui paye pour tout
le monde
donc vous avez les classes populaires
qui a elle qui se sont qui sont
sacrifiés sur l'autel de la mode de la
mondialisation de la modernité et les
classes pauvres et des classes moyennes
paient pour tout le monde et les plus
riches et les entreprises
on leur fait des crédits d'impôt en
permanence donc il ya un ras-le-bol et
il faut trouver des solutions
alors oui augmenter les salaires c'est
une des premières solutions et la
deuxième solution c'est partager les
richesses partagées le temps de travail
et surtout relancer l'activité on a
quand même six millions et demi de
chômeurs dans ce pays et il faudrait
relancer l'activité par un grand plan
d'investissements c'est pour ça que nous
on propose par exemple la transition
écologique il aura besoin d'énormément
de monde il y aura besoin de compétences
de moyens humains pour isoler les
bâtiments pour de nouvelles énergies
renouvelables pour voilà pour toutes ces
choses là pour la grille tu
l'agriculture biologique et c'est un
effet vertueux vous relancer l'emploi
donc la croissance mais une croissance
responsable écologiquement et vous
répartissez aussi la charge de
l'imposition sur quatorze tranches
aujourd'hui il ya cinq tranches dont
tout pèse sur les classes moyennes mais
ça c'est un problème affirme atari ce
que vous vous retrouvez dans ses
discours
c'est difficile de répondre à cette
question je me retrouve pas du tout dans
en fait je me retrouve pas dans vos
discours parce que je les trouve pas
sincère voilà c'est simple j'ai un
problème avec ça
ça manque de sincérité quand vous me
dites d'un côté et bien sûr on comprend
les français
il travaille beaucoup on leur prend part
si on leur prend pas là par là et puis
que derrière la première chose que vous
faites c'est critiquer le mouvement des
jets les jaunes en dix ans qu'on est des
violents concon et l'écho que non le
mouvement populaire ne n'est pas sortie
de nulle part mais il a été beaucoup
poussé par l'extrême droite et compagnie
ça me dérange voilà ça me dérange
énormément
alors vous avez peut-être un blason à
redorer je suis désolé d'être franche
comme ça mais aujourd'hui il ya un gros
problème vous faites partie du système
voilà et quand vous quand on fait partie
d'un système s'extirper de ce système
c'est très compliqué donc ce serait bien
en fait
moi j'appelle l'ensemble des français à
rendre leur carte de parti politique à
rendre leur carte
deux syndicats concret ça va changer que
y aura plus de parties rapides syndicats
ils auront plus d'argent sauf la cgt qui
est financée grandement par l'état aussi
mais ça va changer en fait que on va
tout va il faudrait pas parce qu'en fait
pour qu'on récupère du pouvoir d'achat
il faut sortir de ce système il faut
qu'on concon con qu'on fasse table rase
de ce système où aujourd'hui plus on
paye d'impôts grâce au nice aux niches
fiscales
plus on se fait applaudir et quand on
touche s'emballe de primes d'activité
c'est limite si on n'est pas traité
comme un moins que rien donc à un moment
donné il faut remettre les choses dans
le contexte plus on a d'argent mon pays
d'impôts mieux c'est et quand on n'a pas
d'argent et qu'on peut pas payer
d'impôts et qu'on touche du rsa là tout
de suite on est un parasite de la
société alors que je pense que la
personne qui économise même vingt mille
euros par an en crédits d'impôt cette
personne là c'est un peu plus un
parasite du fisc avait récité les gens à
investir leur argent ailleurs par
exemple alors ça va être des employés
mais si ça peut être justement de la
rénovation énergétique
je vais juste laissé des poules sonia
porot puisque là vous avez nommé mois
déjà le système je sais pas ce que c'est
je connais le système capitaliste essais
et ses conséquences dans l'organisation
du travail et de la société et pour nous
c'est vraiment important de ceux de se
placer dans dance est conflictuelle
itella après
évidemment une organisation comme la cgt
qui a près de 700 mille adhérents
forcément c'est une grosse machine et
faire vivre la démocratie à l'intérieur
on si on s'y emploie et certainement qu
on a aussi des choses et on y réfléchit
et on y réfléchit régulièrement mais en
tout cas nous par exemple on ne se passe
pas dans le cadre des français on défend
l'ensemble des travailleurs français ou
étrangers on se bat pour la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers
et sur la question de l'extrême droite
et on n'est pas épargné et on le combat
à la fois dans ses manifestations on va
dire en général dans la société mais
aussi en interne et on a posé ce cadre
là comme étant voilà quelque chose de
valeurs communes et les idées
nationalistes les idées xénophobes
l'antisémitisme sous le racisme de
sexisme on cherche voilà on cherche à le
combattre et ses poses et moi c'est
quelque chose je parle de la globalité
du mouvement des gilets jaunes c'est pas
quelque chose
voilà que les gilets jaunes se sont
donné les moyens de combattre et et ça
pose je pense ça pose des questions
alors in limbo 12 bientôt à sa fin
malheureusement je vais être obligé on
va être obligé de conclure vous allez
avoir trente secondes pour pour conclure
je commence par vous est ce que
finalement le mouvement des gilet jaune
peut perdurer peut perdurer pardon sans
soutien des syndicats des partis
politiques bien sûr il a démarré sans le
soutien des syndicats et des partis
politiques
il continue toujours cinq mois plus tard
aujourd'hui on s'organise on crée des
assemblées citoyennes voilà il ya pas
mal de groupes qui existe il ya beaucoup
de choses qui se passent ça veut quand
on parle de soutien mais y'a soutenir et
rejoindre voilà les partis politiques et
les syndicats peuvent rejoindre le
mouvement
après on parle d' antisémitisme de
violence et c'est madame je vous invite
à lire les communiqués de presse de
preciado ski de jérôme rodriguez d'eric
drouet de maxi nicole qui sont les
figures médiatiques et aussi de tous les
gilet jaune mais non médiatiques qui
font des communiqués de presse et qui
rappelle sans cesse que nous ne sommes
ni antisémite ni séditieux ni violent ni
factieux voilà randy moss 30 secondes
pour conclure oui donc je comprends tout
à fait ce que vous dites et je suis
assez d'accord j'ai pas de carte dans un
parti on s'organise un peu différemment
à la france un soumise par contre c'est
vrai qu'il faut pas quand même jeté tout
le monde dans le trophée voilà il ya les
syndicats qui sont là pour défendre les
droits des travailleurs et ils le font
comme ils peuvent avec les moyens qu'ils
ont les partis politiques sont là pour
proposer des projets démocratiquement et
le mouvement des gilet jaune à une force
une puissance c'est celle de dépasser
tous les clivages et ça c'est très fier
et nous on a refait une partie d'entre
nous l'ont rejoint individuellement on
continuera à y être mais il faut pas non
plus voilà il faut mais alors d'où je
leur dis juste que dans les récents
ratés m'emmena des syndiqués et des
soigneurs pour 30 îles à sion on sait
que certains adhérents de la cgt ou
d'autres syndicats participent
participent au mouvement est on est on
en est on en discute et c'est
extrêmement extrêmement intéressant
voilà par contre nous justement il ya
des clivages qui nous semblent qui nous
semble important à maintenir voilà la
lutte contre les idées d'extrême droite
le fonctionnement démocratique la
défense des libertés
on est dans une période effectivement
extrêmement compliqué voilà nous en tout
cas on appelle l'ensemble des
travailleurs à la à la journée du 1er
mai c'est la journée des travailleurs
c'est une journée par nature justement
qui rappelle internationalement
l'ensemble des travailleurs dans le
monde ont des intérêts c'est comme ça
qu'est née qu'est née cette journée là
et on va continuer à apporter ces
valeurs là et a essayé aussi d'être
toujours plus proche et plus dans l'
écoute du monde du travail
jo frappe at the keating 36 alors nous
les républicains on a on a soutenu le
mouvement des gilet jaune comme je le
rappelle les son diagnostic était était
le bon c'était une veut pouvoir vivre
notre travail nous on propose des
solutions et je suis d'accord avec randy
nemos tout n'est pas à jeter dans les
partis politiques et les syndicats on
propose des solutions nous on propose 20
milliards d'euros d'économies par an qui
passe par la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale et l'évasion fiscale qui passe
par la lutte des doublons administratifs
voilà je pense que maintenant il est
temps que les gilets jaunes accouche
d'un projet ou de quelque chose parce
que ça va pas pouvoir durer
éternellement
car ce mouvement est récupéré ou en tout
cas je dis pas que le mouvement des
gilet jaune et violents jeudi que des
gens intègres ce mouvement pour faire
passer des idées anticapitalistes
anarchiste violente et c a dépassé le
temps merci en tout cas tous les quatre
d'avoir répondu présent ce soir voilà
c'est la fin de ce sept huit débats à
très bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]